[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
comme d'habitude on vous invite à nous
suivre sur les routes de la réunion à la
rencontre des agriculteurs qui ont
décidé de voir l'exploitation au travers
de ferme auberge pour ce nouveau numéro
c'est au mac que je vous emmène où j'ai
rendez vous avec jean max nativel qui
tient ici la ferme auberge la fenêtre je
sens et le rejoindre sur son
exploitation alors sans perdre une
minute c'est parti
[Musique]
apparemment jean max et déjà affairé on
va le rejoindre
[Musique]
comment ça va jean max ça va bien ça va
bien
des bennes à l'appui à tomber à soit
tombé début des trois jeunes avec ça ça
va ça va ça va mais on sait nous voilà
le ferme auberge de la fenêtre voilà
seul et donc du coup tu accueilles les
gens juste en bas ta ferme auberge voilà
alors à la planète oui je peux à coeur
comme une personne là bas
150 personnes on va dire et tout ce que
tu as et c'est là tout ce qui te propose
la table là bas en bas de tableau
d'autres finalement tout vient de cette
exploitation oui en saison oui bon bah
on va commencer par nous verser à la
jeune et monsieur
[Musique]
les six kilos pour joueurs actuellement
c'est 3 kg le matin 100 kg le soir mais
ces animaux la nounou bernadotte dix
mois 12 mois s'est passé pas
l'engagement de dire si ces douze mois
dix à douze mois et pour ce qui est du
maraîchage qu'est ce que tu fais pousser
ici que tout ici tous types ou aussi bas
on a des périodes où nous fait le chou
chou fleur brocoli la pomme de terre
nous fait deux fois l'année s'est
amorcée en septembre au niveau et piste
où poussent le temps le ps il les
oignons à tout tout pousse et on peut
tout faire incidemment le petit bémol
pour apporter du piment cette année mon
masque c'est bon on a eu des titans les
compliments est tombé tout petit musée
qui a une grosse partie son exploitation
qui est destiné aux fourrages en fait
aux vrais tahrir les animaux voilà j'ai
préféré mettre de la can au lieu du
fourrage qui classique parce que bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
richesses on voit mieux les animaux
pousser et au niveau rentabilité aussi
ses messages sur laquelle fois je me
disais qu'il y avait 10 12 mois
d'engagement la présence forte tête de
bétail ou à la belle on peut on peut
gagner quelques jeux et d'engraissement
par rapport à ça bon on va récupérer
toit pour manger ce midi alors ben c'est
mehdi on va récupérer un peu les pays
anti copé
bah oui allez c'est parti
[Musique]
d'un côté
je suis ici pour ça jean max avec grand
plaisir
l homme a porté des pommes de terre
oui là quelques lapins en liberté ça
fait trois ans on les a mis en liberté
ils ont des petites ou des euros donc
voilà et à combien de superficie ont
tous sur l'exploitation la
l'exploitation ici ben radhia 5 ha oui
bon mais c'est vrai que nous on prévoit
d'agrandir bientôt pour peut-être
d'avoir une dizaine d'écoles
[Musique]
je ne dirais pas de lâcher sa caméra est
venu apporter des femmes de faire avec
moi
[Musique]
et du coup tout ce que là tout ce qui
est planté comme les pommes de terre par
exemple c'est tout tout ça c'est le
produit qu'on va retrouver dans la set
là en bas la table au dos une partie où
ils furent appelés sur un monde
mais c'est un travail il faut pas trop
apprécié ça le concept de la ferme
auberge quoi c'est dire que certes on
accueille des gens certes bien la table
d'hôte bien tout l'aspect exploitation a
été carrément benetton
[Musique]
alors voilà ton poulailler ouais parce
qu'on est parti pour nous garder voilà
dernièrement jean louis
on a produit ici ben en ce moment
peut-être eu au niveau des poules est
payée 2 cents à peu près 200 en liberté
oui en liberté parce que je vois
tellement qu'elle ait quelques copains
en cage
[Musique]
je peux plus
du coup toutes les poules assure liberté
ils sont liberté tout en liberté et bien
voilà depuis dix huit ans jeune et
dorment ou du coup ça brille dans les
branches dans les manches nous c'est
pour ça qu'on laisse un peu de
végétation autour c'est pas que mon bébé
ils peuvent dormir en haut ils sont
protégés pour voir les chiens la nuit
moment si le chien des attaques qui sont
en haut il ya ya ya pas de souci
l'échalas quoi d'autre comme comme
animal qui pourrait les manger la nuit
comment le pape on ne s'y prendrait pas
la nuit par la nuit mais la journée
comme il ya la végétation ils peuvent se
camoufler un peu de sous c'est bon mais
sinon 6,6 être explosé bommel et papon
gobain un poulet d'un kilo acquis le
sens qu'ils vont s'étaler tata des
pertes comme ça chaque année à cause des
amis et tout ça arrive tout le temps et
ça c'est tous les poulets de la même
espèce on est d'accord ça se touche tous
les pays ça c'est le poulet pays c'est
pour faire des coqs de combat or là
dedans ça va peut-être des coupes
l'orangé pour la table d'hôte valable
non seulement pas seulement nous les
coqs
les jeunes comme nous on quand ils sont
arrivés à cet âge et commence à se
bagarrer nous on va les mettre en cage
on va l'essayer et si c'est bon nous on
garde on sélectionne qu'on va faire les
combats est-ce que tu as un coq de
combat que tu pourrais présenter un
champion
on a tous ces cons blague il a par
exemple via par exemple
la libye
et ça fait combien la vente
après tu m'as bien tout dépend si c'est
un bon quand mon balai comme de combat
ça peut aller de 200 euros jusqu'en 2003
[Musique]
on a vu un tas vibrant cage autant avoir
cette ville en
la menace de trois comme le cheikh
bassel et le poulet fermier et pratiques
que nous fait temps en temps pas petites
bonnes et ça c'est uniquement pour la
table par contre d'accord et les garder
comme ça séparés du reste du highway
obligé sinon au pays vous voulez tuer ah
oui effectivement il a commencé
petit club de décoration alors celui-là
il est pas du tout fait pour manger un
il est juste fait pour être jolie et ça
marche plutôt bien mais méchant il est
méchant
ça va je pars piketon maïs
[Musique]
bon bah ça y est on a nourrit le bétail
on a porté les pommes de terre on a
récupéré notre patte ce midi
donc du coup on descend à la table
d'hôtes on va rejoindre daniel la femme
de jean max pour préparer le cari et oui
c'est le poids dont je parle
et voilà monsieur le mieux
en fait la juge je tire des les
mutuelles les servir tout seul en fin de
compte c'est qu'on a tant été ouverts
ici on a commencé table d'hôte
en 97 thème le dot s'était limité à 25
ouvert l'époque et comme nous on avait
une demande un peu plus importante nous
on a décidé de passer fait maubeuge et
voilà à tester moment pour répondre à la
demande en fait c'était pour répondre à
la demande pas dormi après c'est vrai
que l'on a deux chambres d'hôtes et une
capacité de huit places
thual crise les commandes du coup nous
fait le coup les pays nous ont fait
spécialement entre carrie diaries
traditionnels
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi ta version du cari
poulet à toi carré de poules été
fait avec des oignons un petit peu d'ail
de dieu plaint
un petit peu de tomates attentive et les
tomates ah oui parce qu'il ya des gars
qui disent que le charity le pape
tobback le rougail tu mets des tomates à
l'eau dans le car il faut les mois je
mets tout petit peu mais pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup même type et de tomates il
enverra la sauce anti problèmes de
safrans tippett poivre voilà safran
safran pays bah oui
oui
personne n'en travaille en famille c'est
à dire avec notre fils notre belle fille
la plupart du temps où notre fils temps
en temps un coup de magie mais on va y
aller après une matinée bien chargée à
la ferme comme à l'auberge il est temps
de passer à table au menu on a un gratin
chouchou inca et poulet et en dessert
un gâteau qui sont
ces matins il veut
[Musique]
encore monter
dans le joli oreilles
pourtant à première ac
dc - elle est vraiment très bien voilà
toujours en gare
aux cayes la morue chéri qu'elle
mais m
m
[Musique]
on a ça y est on vient de descendre et
de kayes poule est délicieux et jean max
a décidé de m'emmener faire un petit
tour sur les hauteurs des mac pour me
faire découvrir un coin qui connaît et
qu'il affectionne particulièrement
on peut montrer l'endroit où j'ai un peu
grandi parce que mes grands parents
habitaient et ce coin là s'appelle la
plaine bnf dans un endroit isolé on peut
y aller à pied et bien jusqu'à présent
il encore psd des gens qui habitaient là
bas
on vient donc de se poser dans une des
nombreuses aires de pique nique on peut
trouver au mac
à part ça qu'est ce qu'on peut voir ici
juste en rien le point de vue la fenêtre
on a aussi l'observatoire astronomique
que nous on a
mac aventure ce qui est pas très loin il
ya des randonnées à faire il ya là du
côté de la vallée du bois de patates il
ya le piton cabris à on peut aller même
jusqu'aux tapage en descendant en pente
en passant par la pétanque au piton
cabris il ya quand même pas mal de
choses à faire toi tu es au mac depuis
toujours enfin comme c'est vrai que je
suis né à l'étang salé mais j'avais à
peine un mois quand je suis monté au mac
pour habiter du muscle car ce jour donc
et tu faisais quoi avant d'abord où
martin ta ferme que je travaillais dans
une branche qui avait rien à voir avec
le secteur que je suis actuellement
pourquoi avoir choisi l'agriculture
c'est quoi cet avis de l'époque qui
convenait plus c'était vraiment par
conviction a décidé d'admettre que
l'élevage est tout bon bain comme j'aime
bien les animaux aussi bon mais ça va
c'était le c'était de trouver c'est faut
croire que tu aime bien les gens aussi
alors si c'est vrai c'est un métier
qu'on fait pas au niveau de l'activité
touristique l'accueil touristique ont
fait pas d'accueil théorie c'est que si
on n'aime pas les gens c'est sûr aubin
jean-marc je te remercie pour cette
journée je t'en remercie pour un maroc
fait découvrir les maquettes en
exploitation ta vie quotidien son
travail de tous les jours pour moi
c'était un plaisir jean max
à la prochaine à dakar
tchoubaïs
mais
m
et voilà c'est comme ça ex termine cet
épisode cette journée un passé au mac en
compagnie de jean max nativel alors vous
l'aurez compris si vous cherchez un
cadre magnifique et une bonne table vous
donne l'adresse et la ferme auberge la
fenêtre en ce qui nous concerne on se
retrouve sur les routes de la réunion
pour un prochain épisode plus
[Musique]